emmanuel macron était en déplacement ce
jeudi matin l'université paris saclay
une visite pour prendre le pouls du
monde étudiant qui déprime loin des
amphis le président a notamment annoncé
la création d'un chèque psy pour tous
les jeunes qui souhaitent consulter un
remède peut être aux blues ambiant elle
les étudiants sont en effet de plus en
plus démoralisée à l'idée de devoir
rester chez eux pour suivre les courants
distant ciel c'est le cas des nz aux 18
ans qui est en première année à la
faculté des tanneurs à tour samuel colin
est allé le rencontrer chez lui à
montlouis sur loire
enzo est en première année d'anglais 300
élèves dans sa promotion qu'il n'a
jamais rencontré ou presque depuis le
second confinement il reste chez lui
pour suivre cours magistraux et travaux
dirigés sur son ordinateur pour les amis
même chose c'est par visio que ça se
passe pas de vie étudiante à l'horizon
et une situation exceptionnelle qui dure
ce qui manque le plus c'est le contact
humain de l'enseignement tel manque
deschamps jouait de deux
oui des changes parce que c'est un peu
ça aussi c'est là c'est ça la fac aussi
c'est parler échanger discuter sur ordre
des choses lui s'estime chanceux de
vivre en famille et d'être entouré il
devrait peut-être reprendre les cours en
2000 groupe le 26 février
mais l'université se prépare à l'accueil
d'autres filières dès lundi que des
premières années pour commencer objectif
éviter le décrochage entre autres les
deux psychologues de l'université voit
les demandes d'entretien augmenté d'un
tiers en un an où on veut tout mettre en
oeuvre pour que il ya un retour aussi en
présentiel des étudiants parce que ce
dont il souffre aux 6 et d'isolement de
manque de lien social de désocialisation
donc en attendant que l'université
puisse rouvrir pour toutes les années
donc on va essayer de mettre en place
des tiers lieux des lieux de rencontre à
10 personnes maximum avec des activités
pour créer un lien social
l'université a aussi mis en place une
aide alimentaire et une aide à l'achat
d'ordinateurs chacune distribué à 500
étudiants environ